[Music]  how's this for a casual Wednesday night  okay far from it when you're Jennifer  Lopez and Kim Kardashian  JLo hosted a taco fiesta at her home she  shares with boyfriend Alex Rodriguez on  Wednesday and while a rod was nowhere to  be seen Kim couldn't contain her  excitement sharing videos and pics  throughout the night including this  selfie with the hostess Keeping Up with  the Kardashians star rocked a hot pink  fur coat and platinum blonde Bob JLo  dazzled in this sequin jumpsuit Kim and  JLo were joined by Kourtney Kardashian  and Kris Jenner who was snapped hanging  out with Jennifer's mom Guadalupe salsas  and selfies it doesn't get much better  than that  [Music]  you  [Music]